[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصي وفي العناوين
[موسيقى]
انقاذوا امراتين على قيد الحياه من تحت
الانقاض في درنه بعد اسبوع على الفيضانات
المدمره في الشرق الليبي فرق الانقاذ
تواجه تحديات انتشار جثث من مباني جرفتها
السيول الى عرض البحر وعمليات تتسارع في
المدينه لاحتواء انتشار محتمل للاوبئه
وفي المغرب جهود لربط مناطق الزلزال بشبكه
الطرقات السلطات تباشر تنفيذ برنامجها
الطارئ لاواء منكوبي زلزال الحوز ووزاره
التعليم تعلن الاستئناف التدريجي للدراسه
بدءا من الاثنين في المناطق الاكثر تضررا
اليوم الثاني على التوالي احتدام المعارك
في محيط مقر قياده الجيش بالخرطوم والجيش
يقصف مواقع للدعم السريع جنوب ام درمان
حرائق في ابراج ومباني عده في العاصمه
وتبادل للقصر المدفعي في مدينه الابيض
بولايه شمال كردفان
[موسيقى]
ونبدا من تداعيات السيول في ليبيا بعد
مرور اسبوع على الكارثه
[موسيقى]
اذا اعلن الهلال الاحمر الليبي انقاذ
شقيقتين على قيد الحياه في منطقه حي
الصحابه بمدينه درنه وقال متحدث باسم
الهلال الاحمر ان السيدتين اللتين يتراوح
عمرهما بين 20 و 25 عاما
نقلتا الى المستشفى
وتتواصل في الاثناء جهود اجهزه الاسعاف
الليبيه بمسانده فرق اجنبيه للبحث عن
المفقودين وجثث القتلى جراء السيول وبعد
اسبوع على الفيضانات يكثف الهلال الاحمر
جهوده لتجميع المواد الطبيه والغذائيه
لتلبيه احتياجات مدينه درنه وبقيه المناطق
التي اجتاحتها السيول
من دارنا ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره تامر
الصمادي تامر نقترب معك اكثر من المشهد
واخر تطورات عمليات الانقاذ
بالفعل ال سي كلما يغيب او ينقضي يوم
تتعمق الماساه بشكل اكبر لماذا لان فرق
الانقاذ تواجه مساحه حقيقيه المباني مدمره
بشكل كبير وفي عديد المناطق ليس في منطقه
واحده او اثنتين او ثلاثه انما في اغلب
المناطق نستطيع القول بان نصف المدينه او
اكثر بات مدمرا بشكل كبير
الانقاض في كل مكان الركام في كل مكان
فرقه الانقاذ تواجه تحدي الوقت عامل الوقت
الذي بات حاسما في الوصول الى الاف الجثه
التي لا زالت تحت الانقاض اما ابتلعها
ابتلعتها الارض او ابتلعها البحر هنالك
فرق تعمل على مدار الساعه على مدار
الساعات النهار والليل في البحر وفي
اليابسه ايضا
الاخبار لا تبشر بخير حتى هذه اللحظه لان
الامكانيات التي تحدث عنها السلطات
امكانيات شحيحه مقارنه
بهول ما جرى بمقارنه بالخسائر الكبيره
التي يعني فصلت المدينه الى شطرين والحديث
عن الشطر الاكثر تضررا هو الشطر الشرقي من
المدينه لاسيما في منطقه حي الصحابه
ومنطقه وادي درنه والعديد من المناطق التي
تحولت الى انقاض تحولت الى ركام هنالك فرق
غاده تعمل فرق محليه بطبيعه الحال وهنالك
ايضا فرق عربيه وفرق دوليه لكن السلطات
المحليه هنا تقول بان الامكانيات لا تزال
متواضعه مقارنه بهول الماسه
والفاجعه الكبيره كانت هنالك فسحه قليله
من الامل خلال الساعات الماضيه عندما اعلن
عن انتشال يعني شقيقتين في منطقه حي
الصحابه وهما على قيد الحياه لكن هذه تبقى
حالات نادره في ظل ان الاف الجثه ما زالت
تحت الانقاض وبدات الرائحه بشكل كبير تفوح
في ارجاء المدينه وتنتشر في ارجاء المدينه
وهو ما دفع السلطات الى التحذير بشكل كبير
من خطر الوباء ولذلك بدات بعزل عديد
المناطق والحديث يتكرر خلال الساعات
الماضيه عن ربما اقتراب اخلاء المدينه او
اجزاء كبيره من المدينه نحن كنا اقتربنا
من مفاصل المدينه التي تعرضت لكثير من
الاضرار كثير من الدمار واقتربنا من
عائلات الضحايا واعددنا التقرير التالي
نتابع
احياء درنا اتلملموا جراحها
الفاجعه كبيره والخساره اكبر
يحار المرء في ماهيه ما جرى لقد اقتلعت
احياء وطرقات وحياه من جذورها
البشر لا زالوا تحت الانقاض في عداد
المفقودين في عداد الموتى الرائحه
المنبعثه من تحت تلك الانقاض من خلفه
رائحه صعبه للغايه
المحاولات لا زالت متواصله لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه
علي احد ذوي الضحايا لم يستسلم للياس رغم
مروري وقت ثقيل يمني النفس بايجاد اي من
افراد عائله شقيقه العالقين تحت الانقاض
على قيد الحياه
خيال شيء خيال شيء خيال يعني مهما تقول
مرض حتى العالم اللي بره ما يصدقكش والله
المستعان نحن نطلب من الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يوحد البلاد ويهدي لعباد
تبحث فرق الانقاذ عن اي بصيص امل يقودها
الى احياء
تحذيرات تتوالى من حدوث الوباء بقاء الاف
الجثث دون انتشال في ظل شح الادوات ينذر
بكارثه صحيه خطيره
لذلك تعمل السلطات على مواجهه ذلك الخطر
او تاخير وقوعه يحاول محمد اخفاء وجعه لقد
فقد زوجته وطفلته كل شيء اي شيء ما عاد
عندنا شيء طيب العائله بتاعنا كله الصقر
لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله اكثر منك
والله ما عندي حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
وبارك الله في هالناس اللي كلها فزعه
طلبت حياه المدينه راسا على عقب يتحدث
خليل بالم عنتبعات ذلك اليوم الكئيب
وبنته عمي علي عمي علي رحيم هو واولاده
مقر الشرطه العسكريه اثنين اصحاب واحباب
هم الاثنين يعني كارثه يعني مهما ننصف مش
هنوصف فوق متسونامي والله
اينما وليت وجهك في دارنا ستجد خرابا
ودمارا
المدينه غارقه بالجثث غارقه بالهموم غارقه
بالوجع والماساه تتضاعف يوما بعد يوم في
ظل نقص المساعدات والامكانيات
تناشد السلطات ارسال مزيد من المدد تتحدث
عن تضرر الاف المنازل والمباني وتتهيا
لاخلاء اجزاء كبيره من المدينه
قيل كئيبه طويله
تعيشها ما ياملون به هو الوصول الى كامل
الجثامين الى كامل الجثثات التي ابتلعها
البحر في هذه الماساه الكبيره والمحققه
بالمناسبه هذا واحد من اكياس الجثث اكياس
الجثامين التي وفرتها السلطات المحليه
لنقل المتوفين تباعا
لقد تحول البحر الى مقبره كبيره وهو لا
يتوقف عن لفظ من جرفتهم السيول انها
الكارثه بعينها حين لا تبقي ولا تذر تدرس
ماديا الجزيره
قال مراسل الجزيره في ميناء مدينه درنه ان
فرقا من الغواصين تواصل البحث عن الجثث
التي جرفها السيل الى البحر والسواحل اضاف
مراسلنا ان ضعف الامكانيات لدى فرق البحث
يؤخر العثور على مزيد من الجثث او
انتشالها
تشاهدون هذا الذي حدث السيارات التي
تحولت فجاه رمى بها السيل والعرم الى هذا
البحر وعدد كبير من هذه السيارات كانت
طبعا بركابها وعدد منها فقلها اصحابها
بغيه الفرار من هذا الفيضان عندما تنبهوا
الى خطوره الوضع خاصه وانه ضرب في وقت
متاخر من الليل احد الغواصين قال لي انه
يرى عدد كبير من الجثث امامه في السياره
ولكنه لا يقدر على استخراجها من جهه لغياب
الامكانات ومن جهه لان السياره تحطمت
بالكامل هنا عمليات البحث عن الجثث ما
زالت مستمره من خلال الجرافات التي تشتغل
حينما وتتوقف حينا حسب
الاجراءات المتبعه ولكن هذه الجرافات تقوم
بمحاوله كسر الصخر الذي يوجد هنا لانه
ان هنا عدد كبير من الجثث التي العالقه
بين الصخور والتي لا يمكن استخراجها بدون
كسر هذه الصخور هؤلاء بعض المنقذين الذين
ياتون بين الفينه والاخرى لمتابعه عملهم
ولمتابعه ما يمكن اخراج بعض الركام او
البحث عن احتمالات وجود جثث يمكن ان اقول
بشكل مختصر بان هذا البحر يلخص جزءا من
ماساه هذه المدينه هذا البحر الذي كان
يمثل نعمه هو والوادي نعمه هذه المدينه
التقيا على المدينه واصبح نقمه لها ولكن
الغريب ان المدينه التي ربما كانت تخشى من
حدوث تسونامي ياتي من البحر لكن السيل
فاجاها من الجبل وليس من البحر وجاءها
فجاه وحمل الجميع كل ما صدف في طريقه الى
البحر
من بنغازي ينضم الينا الدكتور تامر رمضان
رئيس بعثه الاتحاد الدولي للصليب والهلال
الاحمر في ليبيا مرحبا بك دكتور تامر
رمضان ما المطلوب من اجل التعامل مع هذه
الازمه التي
شرحها لنا قبل قليل محمد البقالي مراسلنا
في درنا ما المطلوب من اجل ان تتمكن فرق
الانقاذ من استخراج الجثث العالقه في
البحر
مساء الخير وشكرا لاتاحه الفرصه لقاء
الضوء على الوضع في دارنا طبعا زي ما
اتفضل الزميل واشار الوضع في منتهى
الصعوبه
المستجبين على الارض بيقوموا بكل ما
يستطيعونه من جهود لكن الكارثه كبيره وعدد
الضحايا كبير جدا المطلوب هو تضافر الجهود
وتوفير الامكانيات اللازمه للتعامل مع هذه
الازمه مع اذا كنا بنتكلم بالاساس عن
المتوفين والجسانين فيجب توفير اولا الفرق
المدربه
وهنا يجب ان تشير الى ان جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر ليبيا لديها فرق مدربه على اعلى
مستوى للتعامل مع الجسامين ولها تاريخ
طويل في ذلك كذلك توفير اكياس الجسمين
باعداد تتناسب مع اعداد الضحايا طبعا ما
كانش في حد يتخيل يكون في كارثه فيها كل
هذا العدد من المتوفين في نفس التوقيت
الالتزام بالمعايير
العالميه في التعامل مع الجسامين وهي اخذ
جميع البيانات عن الشخص المتوفى وتصويره
واخذ بعض المعلومات الاخرى والبصمات
وخلافه قبل وضعه في الكيس الجثمان حتى
يستطيع ذؤوه ان هم يتعرفوا عليه او يلاقوه
فيما بعد وتفنو بطريقه لائقه تتناسب معك
الغارقه في البحر والعالقه في سياراتها في
داخل البحر هناك صعوبه في استخراج هذه
الجثثمين وهناك كما يبدو نقص في الامكانات
ما الامكانات المطلوبه لتجاوز هذه المشكله
والعمل على حلها واستخراج هذه الجسامين
بالنسبه للجسمين الموجوده في البحر زي ما
تفضل الزميل ان في بعض الفرق المجهزه
بادوات الغطس وادوات انتشال الجثث سواء من
البحر او من البر الادوات دي موجوده يا
اما مش موجوده يا اما موجوده باعداد قليله
يجب توفير اعداد اكبر واطقم عامله عليها
بحيث
نستطيع التشال اكبر من الجسامين في الوقت
اللازم قبل ان يعني يعلن انهاء عمليات
البحث والانقاذ اما بالنسبه للجسمين على
البر او في سيارتهم او كذا دي يعني
استخرجها يكون اسهل الا اذا كانت السياره
مثلا في مكان صعب الوصول اليه فبيكون
الاستعانه بارتفاع المدني وادواتهم
الاليات الثقيله التي تستطيع الوصول
لارتفاعات كبيره او لفتح السيارات اذا
كانت السياره يعني غير يوم لا يمكن فتحها
بسهوله حتى يمكن استخراج الجثمين ثم
التعامل معه طيب
ما المرحله التي وصلت اليها عمليات
الانقاذ اليوم ما ابرز ما انجز حتى الان
ابرز ما انجز حتى الان هو
اولا التعامل مع الناجين
النجعوا من السيل بطريقه سليمه وتوفير قدر
الامكان حسب الامكانيات المتاحه ماوى لهم
حيث فقدوا طبعا بيوتهم الهلال الاحمر
الليبي عامل ماوى مؤقت
الضحايا كذلك سيتم توجيه فرق متخصصه من
الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر في اداره ماوى وفي الماء
والاصحاح وفي
الخدمات الصحيه
والمستشفيات الميدانيه المتنقله والملف
الثالث هو التعامل مع الجثامين كما افردنا
ويمكن يعني اذا حبينا نقول
يعني
خبر قد يكون ايجابي هو
انا اسف جدا
خبر قد يكون ايجابي هو ان ما زال فيه حتى
اليوم استخراج
ناس على قيد الحياه من تحت الانقاذ
والركام فقد يكون يعني لمحه نور في وسط
الاخبار السيئه اللي احنا بنعيشها شكرا
جزيلا لك يا دكتور تامر رمضان رئيس بعثه
الاتحاد الدولي للصليب والهلال الاحمر في
ليبيا
ينضم الينا من داخل مقر الرئاسه وزراء
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه في طرابلس مراسل
الجزيره احمد خليفه احمد مرحبا بك ويبدو
اننا بانتظار مؤتمر صحفي لفريق الطوارئ
الحكومي في طرابلس ماذا في التفاصيل
المؤتمر الصحفي للفريق الحكومي انتهى
اليوم سردت فيه معلومات
حول تطورات العمليات عمليات الانقاذ
وعمليات الخدمات الحكوميه وما يتعلق بعمل
المؤسسات والادارات الحكوميه في مدينه
درنه ولعل ابرز ما ذكره الناطق الرسمي
محمد حموده في هذا المؤتمر انه قال ان
الحكومه تسعى الى عدم انقطاع الامدادات
على مدينه درنه وانها وان الحكومه تعمل
بكامل طاقاتها وتقومها ومؤسساتها لامداد
درنا بالمياه وتحدث عن تحركات رئيس
الحكومه في هذا الصدد وايضا قال ان
الحكومه تتواصل مع المنظمات الدوليه
والمنظمات المحليه
بيئه التعاون
فيما يتعلق بالامدادات الغذائيه والاغاثيه
والدوائيه لمدينه درنه تقريبا هذا هو ملخص
المؤتمر الصحفي للفريق الحكومي والذي
اقتصر اليوم على حضور ثلاثه اشخاص فقط
ابرزهم الناطق الرسمي باسم الحكومه في
سياق متصل اخر التقينا اليوم رئيس الحكومه
انهم اعضاء في هذه اللجنه احمد
الفريق الحكومي تقريبا اكثر من سته عشر او
سبعه عشر شخصا بينهم وزراء في الحكومه هذا
الفريق برئاسه وزير الحكم المحلي بحكومه
الوحده الوطنيه بدر الدين التومي ومعه عدد
من الوزراء وكلاء الوزارات وهذا المؤتمر
يعقد بصفه يوميه يوم امس كان حضور المؤتمر
هنا داخل هذا المقر المركزي الاعلامي
لرئاسه للحكومه هنا في العاصمه طرابلس كان
الحضور قرابه سبعه اشخاص او ثمانيه اشخاص
ابرزهم وزير البيئه ووزيره العدل وكان
معهم وزير الحكم المحلي ورئيس الفريق
الحكومي بحكومه الوحده الوطنيه اشكرك حتى
الساعه احمد خليفه مراسلنا من طرابلس
ينضم الينا صفوان المسوري عضو المجلس
الاعلى للدوله عن مدينه درنه مرحبا بك سيد
صفوان هناك لغت حول موضوع اخلاء مدينه
درنه من اجل افتح المجال امام عمليات
انقاذ اوسع هل اتخذ قرار بهذا الشان
هل علمنا ماذا سيكون عليه الامر هل سيتم
اخلاء المدينه ام لا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا على
الاستضافه مره اخرى تحيه لحضراتكم ولكل
المشاهدين
الحقيقه ان هذا القرار لازال قيد البحث
بالنسبه للسلطات هنا في المنطقه الشرقيه
وحكومه السيد حماد
فيه تذكير في جدي في هذا الموضوع ولكن
فيه ايضا محاوله
ان يكون هذا
الاخراج
كما تبقى من السكان او او
يعني تحديد هذه المنطقه بشكل
مصغر ودقيق جدا حتى لا تصغر حتى لا تكبر
الرقعه وبالتالي يعني تشمل عدد سكان اكثر
يعني في محاوله
لحصر هذه المنطقه
بشكل دقيق
حتى الان حتى الان لم يتخذ القرار ولكن
يناقش باستمرار لان هناك تابعات اخرى
ستحدث عندما يتخذ هذا القرار طيب سيد
صفوان انتم في المجلس الاعلى للدوله ما هو
دوركم في هذه المرحله في وسط كل ما يحصل
الدوله يتابع
ما حدث في دارنا منذ اليوم الاول
ويحاول الدوله ان يتتبع ما يحدث وشكل لجنه
لذلك
سيرفض الميزانيه
لما يحدث في دمنا من الميزانيه من ميزانيه
مخصصه
للمجلس اليوم عقد المجلس جلسه في طرابلس
لم احضرها بالطبع لسبب وجوده في درنه ولكن
كانت كلها
مصبه على ما حدث في الشرق وفي درنه
ويعني في محاوله
للتركيز على
مد المدينه بما تستحقه من مواد اضافيه
وطبيبيه
والتفكير حتى في تقديم
مقترح للمرحله
القادمه فيما يتعلق
بالاعمار واعاده التاهيل
طيب اليوم ايضا سيد صفوان برزت ازمه اخرى
بموازاه كل ما يحدث هي ازمه الالغام التي
يبدو ان الفيضان جرفها بشكل عشوائي على
طرق المحيطه
بدرنوه الى درنه كيف يتم التعامل مع هذه
الازمه حاليا
لم اسمع بهذه الازمه حقيقه
على الاقل يعني انا الى الى مساء اليوم
كنت قريب جدا من مواقع
التنظيف المفقودين في منطقه الوادي
لم اسمع بذلك المشكله التي تبرز الان
وحديث الساعه والتي تحتاج الى تفكير
وايجاد حلول هي مشكله تلوث مياه الشرب في
تلك المنطقه والان التفكير الجاري في
حلحله هذا الامر يعني من حيث توفير مياه
شرب من خارج المدينه وايضا محاوله حفر
ابار في نطاقات ابعد تكون مضمونه وغير غير
ملوثه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر صفوان المسوري عضو
المجلس الاعلى للدوله عن مدينه درنه حدثنا
من دارنا
وتواجه الفرق العامله في دارنا تحديات
كبيره خلال العمليات البحث والانقاذ بسبب
قوه السيول التي جرفت الاف الاشخاص في
طريقها مما صعب تحديد حجم الكارثه بدقه
وعدد الضحايا والمفقودين بروتوكولات
التعامل مع مساله المفقودين خلال الكوارث
نتعرف عليها في العرض التالي
في اعقاب الكثير من الكوارث والاسيما
الكبيره منها تطلع السلطات والمنظمات
والمجتمعات المحليه والسكان والمتطوعون
بمهام عمليه انتشار وجمع الجثث وادارتها
الفوريه ويعرقل جهود الانقاذ والبحث عن
المفقودين والجثه في حاله ليبيا تركم
الحطامي وغمر المياه لاماكن كثيره لهذا
تشير بروتوكولات الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيه
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر الى ضروره
الاسراع في تحديد الوكاله المسؤوله في
مجال اداره الجثث مع منحها مطلق الصلاحيات
والمسؤوليات التي تشمل جمع المعلومات
وتوحيدها ووضعها في سجل المركزي مع
التواصل مع الناس في هذا السياق جاء اعلان
النائب العام الليبي وضع خطه بالتعاون مع
وزاره الداخليه والصحه لتحديد جثث
المفقودين والتعرف على هويتهم ووفق دليل
اداره الجثث بعد الكوارث للاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيه الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
ينبغي جمع وتصويرها فوتوغرافيا باسرع وقت
ممكن قبل تحللها وجمع المعلومات الاساسيه
عنها مع تسجيلها وتخصيص رمز دليلي خاص لكل
جثه وينبغي تخزين الجثث مؤقتا لحمايتها
وتيسير التعرف على هويات اصحابها كما يجب
وضع قائمه تضم اسماء المفقودين وجمع
المعلومات عنهم
تحديد هويه الجثث تحد اخر عام 84 وضع
الانتربول بدعم من الفريق العامل المعني
بتحديد هويه ضحايا الكوارث اول دليل
للتحديد هويه ضحايا الكوارث ويمر ذلك
باربع مراحل اولاها فحص مسرح الحدث ويمكن
ان يستغرق اياما او حتى اسابيع وبيانات ما
بعد الوفاه من خلال مختصين في الادله
الجنائيه بما يساعد على تحديد هويه الضحيه
وبيانات ما قبل الوفاه بتحصيل السجلات
الطبيه او المتعلقه بالاسنان وبصمات
الاصابع والبصمه الوراثيه ثم مطابقه
معلومات الضحايا من لم تحدد هويتهم
بالمعلومات عن المفقودين لعل الحاله
الليبيه في خصوصيتها مع جرف السيول الالاف
ومساحات واسعه ومبانيه وسيارات تكمل في
صعوبه تحديد العدد الحقيقي والنهائي
للضحايا بل والمفقودين ففي ظروف الفوضى
التي تسود في حالات الكوارث كمثال غالبا
ما يتم الابلاغ عن شخص مجهول المصير عده
مرات لجهات مختلفه من جانب افراد اسرته
والى ان تتضح الصوره يبقى عداد الموت
والمفقودين مفتوحا فالعثور على جثث يعني
بدايه مسار للتعرف عليها لكن المفقود يبقى
اكبر ضاغط نفسي على عائلات تنتظر خبرا
بشانه وقد لا تعرف عائله اخرى اصلا ان
لديها مفقودين في السيول ففي حالات عده
جرفت السيول عائله ممتده باكملها فغرقت
معها قصتها ولم يبقى منها من يرويها
الى المغرب وجهود احتواء تدعيه الزلزال
[موسيقى]
الى المغرب حيث تتواصل اعمال الاغاثه بعد
تسعه ايام من زلزال الحوز اذ تواصلوا
الهيئات الاغاثيه جهودها لاواء المنكوبين
وعلاج الجرحى يتزامن ذلك مع بدء تفعيل
البرنامج الحكومي الطارئ لاواء من فقدوا
منزلهم
في غضون ذلك قالت وزاره التعليم المغربيه
ان دراسه ستستانف بشكل تدريجي ابتداء من
يوم غد الاثنين في المناطق الاكثر تضررا
من زلزال الحوز وقد بدات وزاره التعليم
المغربيه بنصب 150 خيمه وستجهزها بالمعدات
التربويه والتدريبيه اللازمه والالواح
الشمسيه لاستخدامها كمدارس وقالت وزاره
التعليم ان الاستئناف التدريجي للعمليه
التعليميه سيكون عبر ثلاثه انماط هي
الدراسه في الخيام والدراسه في الوحدات
المتنقله بالاضافه الى نقل المؤسسات
التعليميه بتلاميذها وكوادرها من المناطق
المتضرره الى مناطق اخرى امنه وبعيده
وقال مدير المركز الاستشفائي الاقليمي
بمدينه تارودانت المغربيه ان المركز
يستقبل نحو 130 مصابا يوميا اضاف ان وزاره
الصحه ترسل بعض المصابين لمستشفيات مدن
المجاوره لتسريع عمليه علاجهم مراسل
الجزيره ايمن الزبير رفض لنا جانبا من
اوضاع هؤلاء المصابين وظروفهم في احد
مستشفيات مدينه تارودانت
مع وصول فرق الانقاذ الى بعض القرى في
اقليم تارودانت يتواصل تدفق بعض الجرحى
على المركز
الاستشفائي الاقليمي في مدينه تارودانت
قصص
تروي كيف كانت
ليله الفاجعه وايضا كيف نجا بعض سكان
القرى المنكوبه مثل سعيد سعيد الحمد لله
على السلامه ديالكم
كيف نجوتم يعني من هذه الكارثه
الدوار كامل ان شاء
الله يرحم الوالدين انا مشيت
الحمد لله والشكر لله
والشكر لله
ونشكره الان الاطباء هنا في هذا المستشفى
يقدمون العلاج هناك حديث عن وصول ما يناهز
130 مصاب يوميا الى هذا المركز الاستشفائي
جميع الحالات جميع انواع الاصابات التي
يمكن تصورها توفدت على المستشفى واغلبيه
ديالها هي الكسور في الاطراف وفي الحوض
وفي الراس هذه العلاج ديالها وبتنسيق مع
المديريه الجهويه
بالاضافه الى هذه المستشفيات التابعه
لوزاره الصحه هناك ايضا مستشفيات ميدانيه
اقامها الجيش المغربي بدورها تعالج
المصابين وتخضع بعضهم لعمليات جراحيه ايمن
الزبير الجزيره من المركز
الاستشفائي الاقليمي في مدينه تارودانت
من اسني في اقليم الحوز مركز الزلزال ينضم
الينا مراسل الجزيره المختار العلاوي
المختار كيف يتطور المشهد حيث انت وماذا
عن موضوع
امكانيه استئناف الدراسه في هذه المناطق
نعم بالفعل نحن عمليا الان بدانا ندخل
تدريجيا الاسبوع الثاني من هذا الزلزال
بدات نوعيا الى حد ما عمليه استقرار خصوصا
بعد انتهاء معظم عمليات الانقاذ وفتح
تقريبا جميع الطرق الرئيسيه لا يزال
الاشتغال قائما على الطرق القرويه ولكن
هناك ايضا
انخفاض في درجات الحراره هنا في اسني قبل
قليل كانت هناك زخات مطريه لكن كانت خفيفه
في مناطق اخرى وبحسب النشره التي اصدرتها
هيئات المراقبه الارصاد الجويه نشر
انذاريه توقعت تساقطات مطريه رعديه قويه
في بعض مناطق الشمال الشرقي من المغرب في
مقدمتها وجده هذا على مستوى التحولات
المناخيه على مستوى الاستعداد للدراسه
هناك
على قدم وساق الخيام المدرسيه بدات تنتشر
تم انشاء اكثر من 150 خيمه مدرسيه ستشكل
لبنات لمدارس جديده عوض المدارس الاخرى
التي
تضررت بشكل كبير بفعل بفعل الهزات الارضيه
وايضا تم بناء خيمات كبيره ستكون عباره عن
مدرسه خيمات تشكل مدرسه وخيمه كبيره تشكل
المدرسه بالاضافه لنا التعليم حسب وزاره
التربيه سيكون ايضا عبر وحدات متنقله بدا
ايصالها تدريجيا الى المناطق المتضرره وفي
اماكن اخرى خاصه تلك المناطق التي دمرت
بشكل كبير سيتم نقل المدارس بالتلاميذ
بالاساتذه بالكوادر الى مناطق اخرى وخصوصا
في مراكش وخلال الساعات الماضيه راينا
حافلات تنقل مئات من التلاميذ الى مراكش
جدا لبدء العمليه يوم غد ستكون العمليه
ايضا يوم غدوه بحسب السلطات المحليه هنا
في اسني ستبدا عمليه مراقبه تقنيه للمباني
50 الف منزل من المفروض ان يتم تحديد وضعه
التقني خلال اقل من اسبوعين لتبدا مسطره
الاجراءات وبالتزامن مع ذلك تستمر عمليات
الانقاذ والدعم الذي تقوم به مختلف
الهيئات ومن تلك الهيئات الهلال الاحمر
المغربي جمال حفيظ
بالهلال الاحمر عضو ما الاعمال التي
تقومون بها خصوصا في الاسبوع الثاني من
الزلزال نعم هي ساعات قليله قبل بعد
الفاجعه استجاب متطوع الهلال الاحمر
للتنقل الى المناطق المنكوبه قصدها تقديم
الاسعافات الاوليه والمساعده في انتشار
الجثث وتقديم الدعم النفسي للمنكوبين
وتقديم المس للمتضررين ونحن الان في
الاسبوع الثاني لازلنا في المخيم الميداني
باسمي للمنكوبين
مستمرين في احصاء
وتقديم الدعم وتحسيس
المنكوبين هنا كما اننا نقوم باعمال
لتقديم المساعدات
للنساء الحوامل والرضع قصده جمال على هذا
المعطيات وايضا بالاضافه الى هذا كان
ملاحظا خلال هذين يومي العطله السبت
والاحد تواصل القوافل التضامنيه التي اتت
من جميع المدن المغربيه لدعم المنكوبين
خصوصا مع بدء الانخفاض التدريجي ونحن الان
في اسني بدانا نحس بانخفاض درجه الحراره
خلال هذه الليله
الشكر مختار
العدلاوي كنت معنا من
اسني في اقليم الحوز المركز الزلزال شكرا
لك
بالعوده الى موضوع ليبيا والتطورات في
درنه ينضم الينا من طرابلس محمد الحويج
وزير الاقتصادي والتجاره في حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه مرحبا بك سيد محمد الحويج كيف
تقيم عمل فريق الطوارئ الحكومي في حكومه
الوحده حتى الان
شكرا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحقيقه اولا
عزينا انفسنا ونعزي اهلنا في درنا والجبل
الاخضر
واتمنى لشهدائنا الابرار الجنه نحن
الحقيقه كلامي اليوم موجه للخارج اكثر من
الداخل لان نحن في الداخل هذا واجبنا
وقمنا ونقوم وسنقوم بما يتطلبه نحن دائما
مقصرين اولا للخارج النيران ليبيا
موحده واهل ليبيا يد واحده مؤسساتها
الامنيه العسكريه والاجهزه الاقتصاديه
ورجال الاعمال والقطاع العام والخاص الان
بكل جهدهم متركز في المناطق المتضرره ولان
من التواصل عمال لجنه الطوارئ واللجان
العامله هناك ان الغذاء والدواء متوفر
باكثر حتى من الحاجه وهذا خطوات الحقيقه
الخطوه الاولى لما اجتمعت مجلس الوزراء
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
مجلس الوزراء تعليمات الانتقال كل شركات
الخدمات الى الشرق بكل امكانياتها بكل ما
تملك بالاضافه بناء على ذلك وزاره
الاقتصاد وضعت ثلاثه مراحل للعمل
بالتنسيق مع اخواتنا في البلديات الشرقيه
وفي المناطق الشرقيه وفي القيدات الشرقيه
وكنا متعاونين يد واحده وفي عدد من
الوكلاء سواء في الصناعه او الاقتصاد
موجودين للتواصل معنا فمرينا بثلاث مراحل
المرحله الاولى اللي هو تحريك رجال
الاعمال
والغرفك بالقول انك تتحدث للخارج لماذا
تتحدث للخارج من هو هذا الخارج التي
تخاطبه بان هناك من يفهم كان الليبيين
واحده نحن يد واحده يد قويه لان ثبتت ان
درنا خلقت وطن
خارج اريد ان انقل اليك ما قاله اليوم
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني هو يقول ان عمليه
الانقاذ والمساعده صعبه بسبب غياب حكومه
فاعله في ليبيا
هذا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني يقول وانا
اقول عفوا سيدتي سيدتي خلينا نكمل اقول
فكل اليوم القطاع الخاص من رجال الاعمال
واصحاب الشركات كل الاغذيه والادويه
والمعدات الان متواجده في المناطق الشرقيه
بالاضافه بالاضافه ان كل هذه المرحله
الاولى المرحله الاولى لابد نوفر الغذاء
نوفر الدواء نوفر
الامكانيات اللي تحتاج المرحله الاولى
والانقاذ وغيرها المرحله الثانيه لندخل
اللي هو يسموا فيه تعويض الضرر لان لابد
فيني فقط سيارته في لفقد رزقه في لفقد كذا
ولذلك البرلمان صدر قرار ب 10 مليار دينار
للدخول لهذه المرحله المرحله الثالثه اللي
هو اعمار درنا اقتصاديا والمناطق المتضرره
الاخرون يقول ما يقولون نحن نقول ما نقول
اليوم اللي قدرنا اكررها درنا خلقه وطن
فعلا واصبحت
الامكانيات سيد سيد محمد انت تقول ان
الامكانيات متوفره وان المساعدات تصل ولكن
في المدينه هناك مناشدات بان هناك ضعف
المساعدات وضعف في الامكانات
ربما هناك ربما هناك يسموا فيه التنظيم
فقط لكن مساعدات متوفره بتواصل ان نتواصل
مع اخواننا في الشرق وفي سواء كان الغرف
سواء كان البلديات سواء كان اللجان
الطوارئ كلهم يقولوا ربما ناحيه تنظيميه
اوروبا ما ايضا هذا الكلام في الايام
الاولى ايضا نحن مش في الايام الاولى
اليوم مر كم يوم اليوم دخلنا للمرحله
الثانيه اللي هو انقاذ طبعا هناك بعض
الاشياء ربما يقصدها اللي هم نتيجه اليسار
من
الكارثه نتاع الوادي وغيرها هذه امور
اداريه موجوده في الشرق لكن الامكانيات
الغذاء والدواء وحتى السكن بدا الان حله
فهذا موجود وعليك سؤال حتى الناس
المتواجدين لان عندنا ناس متواجدين هناك
وهم بلغوا لنا هذا الموضوع في دواء وفي
غذاء اكثر من المطلوب
مرضك على ما ذكرت ان وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني قال وهذا يعني الكلام
يقال لان الدول الخارج تتعاطف مع ليبيا في
هذه المحنه وتريد المساعده هو يقول انه لا
توجد حكومه فاعله
محمد الحوائج وزير والاقتصاد والتجاره في
حكومه الوحدات الوطنيه من طرابلس شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث تجددت المعارك الضاريه في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش في العاصمه
وتزامن ذلك مع اندلاع حرائق في مباني
حكوميه ورئيسيه بالخرطوم وستقصف متبادل
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع واتهم
الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني من سماها
المتمرده باحراق مباني شركه النيل الكبرى
للبترول
وزاره العدل وهيئه المواصفات والمقاييس
يعود مقر القياده العامه وسط العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم الى واجهه التطورات
الميدانيه في ظل استمرار موجه المعارك
والاشتباكات العنيفه في محيطه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع التي اندلعت مساء
السبت الماضي وانهت هدوءا قارب الاسبوعين
تبادل القصف بين الطرفين ادى كذلك الى
تصاعد اعمده الدخان الكثيفه في سماء
الخرطوم اثرا اندلاع النيران في عده مباني
رئيسيه ابرزها البرج الذي يضم مقرا ومكاتب
شركه النيل للبترول
المواجهات امتدت الى رقعه واسعه شملت مدن
العاصمه الثلاث الخرطوم وخرطوم بحري وام
درمان فضلا عن مدينه الاوبيض غربيه البلاد
اذ اكد مصدرا في الجيش السوداني تدمير
الجيش قوه من الدعم السريع الشرقيه مطار
الخرطوم وكبدها خسائر في الارواح والمعدات
كما هاجم بالطيران والمدفعيه الثقيله
مواقع لخصومه جنوبيه وشرقي الخرطوم اضافه
الى عده مناطق في الخرطوم بحري واضافه الى
هجومها على مقر القياده العامه تقول قوات
الدعم السريع انها قصفت اهدافا في منطقه
سلاح المهندسين وسطاء ام درمان كما اتهمت
في بيان لها الجيش بتعمده قصف البنى
التحتيه والمناطق الحيويه في الخرطوم مثل
وزاره العدل وديوان الضرائب وبرج شركه
النيل للبترول وتزامنت هذه المعارك
المتبادله مع عوده رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان الى البلاد بعد انهائه
زياره رسميه لاوغندا استمرت يوما واحدا في
خطوه تعد السادسه من نوعها منذ مغادرته
مقر قياده قواته وسط الخرطوم قبل ثلاثه
اسابيع واتخاذه مدينه بورتسودان مقرا
مؤقتا وسط معلومات تحدثت عن اعتزام
البرهان تشكيل حكومه طوارئ لاداره البلاد
الى حين التوصل الى تسويه تنهي الحرب
المستمره منذ منتصف ابريل الماضي في حين
هدد قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو بتشكيل حكومه موازيه بالخرطوم وقال
في تسجيل صوتي الخميس الماضي ان قواته
ستبدا مشاورات لتشكيل ما سماها سلطه مدنيه
بالمناطق الخاضعه لسيطرتها
قال ما يعرف بالاطار الاستراتيجي الدائم
للحركات الازوديه ان عناصره سيطر على
قاعده عسكريه للجيش المالي في منطقه ليره
في اقليم ازوات قرب الحدود مع موريتانيا
بعد مواجهات اندلعت مساء الاحد كما اعلن
الاطار اسقاط مروحيه تابعه للجيش المالي
وكان الجيش المالي قد اعلن قبل ساعه ان
المنطقه تعرضت لهجوم دون تقديم تفاصيل
اضافيه او حصيله لهذا الهجوم ويعيش اقليم
ازواد على وقع توتر اعقب بدء انسحاب
القوات الامميه وسع كلا الطرفين الى
السيطره على مواقع جديده الله اكبر
قال الجيش المالي ان الرد جار على الهجوم
الذي استهدف قاعده ليرا وان على السكان
تجنب الحركه قرب مواقع الاشتباك وكانت
الحركات الازوديه قد تبنت الهجوم على
معسكر للجيش المالي في بلده ليره شمال
غربي مالي قرب الحدود مع موريتانيا وقالت
ملصقيه الحركات الازواديه انها سيطرت على
المعسكر واسقطت الطائره للجيش المالي كانت
تغير على المسلحين في البلده
ونبقى في اجواء التوتر بمنطقه الساحل
الافريقي حيث وقعت مالي والنيجر وبوركينا
فاسو وهي ثلاث دول في منطقه الساحل بغرب
افريقيا تحكمها مجالس عسكريه وقعت اتفاقا
امنيا تعهدت من خلاله بمساعده بعضها بعضا
في حال وقوع اي تمرد او عدوان خارجي من
جانب اخر قال المجلس الانتقالي في النيجر
ان تحركات الجنود التشاديين على اراضي
النيجر جرت وفق تنسيق رسميا مع جهه
المختصه في البلاد
تحالف عسكري جديد في غرب افريقيا ذاك الذي
وقع ميثاقه في العاصمه الماليه باماكو بين
ثلاث دول هي مالي والنيجر وبوركينا فاسو
اي مساس بالسياده الاقليميه لطرف او اكثر
من الاطراف الموقعه على هذا الميثاق يعتبر
اعتداء على الاطراف الاخرى ويلزم جميع
الاطراف بتقديم المساعده والعون بما في
ذلك استخدام القوه العسكريه لضمان الامن
في الفضاء الذي يشمله هذا التحالف
تحالف دول الساحل جاء مدفوعا بالمخاوف
المشتركه والمواقف المتقاربه والاوضاع
المتشابهه فالدول الثلاث تجمعها حدود
طويله مشتركه وهي خاضعه لحكم عسكري بعد
انقلابات ناجحه اثارت انتقادات اقليميه
ودوليه ينص ميثاق التحالف على الدعم
المتبادل بين الاطراف الموقعه لمكافحه
الارهاب والجريمه المنظمه
ولمواجهه اي انتهاك لسياده او وحده اراضي
واحده او اكثر من الدول الثلاث بما في ذلك
استخدام القوات المسلحه
التحالف الجديد يبدو تتويجا لموقف دوله
الاعضاء من المستجدات الجيوسياسيه الاخيره
في افريقيا حيث اصطفت مالي وبوركينا فاسو
مع قاده النيجر الجدد بعد ان هددت
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
من اجل استعاده النظام السابق كما ان تلك
التحولات تعيد الان رسم خريطه التحالفات
في غرب القاره فالدول ثلاث قررت الابتعاد
عن فرنسا التي ترتبط معها باتفاقات امنيه
وعسكريه طويله الامد لصالح روسيا والصين
قوتي النفوذ الجديدهتين في افريقيا
ترسيخا لذلك المنحل التقى النقيب ابراهيم
تراوري رئيس المجلس العسكري الحاكم في
بوركينا فاسو وفدا عسكريا روسيا في
العاصمه يوم السبت وفي اليوم نفسه اجتمع
رئيس المجلس العسكري في النيجر عبد الرحمن
تشاني مع المبعوث الصيني الخاص للشؤون
الافريقيه في البلدين كما في مالي تمضي
موجه التوجه شرقا بنسق متسارع اذ يستفيد
القاده العسكريون من موجه عداء شعبي
متزايد ضد فرنسا ووجودها العسكري الاخذ
بالانحسار بعد الغاء القاده الجدد معظم
الاتفاقيات الموقعه مع المستعمر السابق
[موسيقى]
دعت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل
فوندرلايند والاتحاد الاوروبي لاستضافه
جزء من المهاجرين غير النظاميين الذين
يصلون الى سواحل ايطاليا قادمين من شمال
افريقيا وشهدت جزيره لامبي دوزا الايطاليه
الصغيره حاله من التوتر خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه بعد تدفق قوارب تحمل الاف
المهاجرين وطالبي اللجوء الى سواحلها
ليست هي الحلم لكنها في طريقه
لامبيلوسا هي بوابه المهاجرين غير
النظاميين الى السواحل الاوروبيه
لا يكمل جميعهم رحله عبور المتوسط فامام
خفر السواحل وسفن الانقاذ الايطاليه من
العمل الكثير اغلب الناجين ينتهي بهم
المطاف في مراكز استقبال بلغت طاقه
استيعابها القصوى
تخشى السلطات الايطاليه من استنزاف
قدراتها اللوجستيه والاداريه
ويخشى سكان جزيره المتوسطيه الصغيره
المنتفضون اكثر من ذلك
اذ بلغهم ان العام بيدوسا وصلها خلال
اليومين الماضيين فقط نحو 8,500 طالب هجره
او لجوء على متن 199 قاربه
انها ازمه ضاغطه منذ بدايه العام على
حكومه جورجيا ميلوني
تخفيف الضغط هو تحديدا ما تعد به خطه
طرحتها رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه التي
تزور الجزيره الايطاليه وميناءها هناك
وقفت ارسولا فوندر لاين على خطوره الوضع
ومن هناك حضت على توزيع افضل لطالبي لجوء
بين الدول الاوروبيه
جئت الى هنا لاقول لكم جميعا مره اخرى ان
الهجره تمثل تحديا اوروبيا وتحتاج الى حل
وردا اوروبيين ان الاجراءات الملموسه هي
التي ستحدث التغيير على ارض الواقع
ويمكنكم الاعتماد على الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاتحاد وعد ايضا بتسريع الدعم المالي
لتونس التي ينطلق من سواحلها غير البعيده
غالبيه المهاجرين غير النظاميين كما تنص
الخطه على محاوره ابرز دول الافريقيه التي
ياتون منها لاعادتهم في حال لم يستوفوا
شروط اللجوء
التعامل مع نقاط الانطلاق والعبور في
الضفه الجنوبيه لا يغني باي حال عن دعم
اولى نقاط الوصول فما الذي ستناله روما
حقا من مؤسسات بروكسل
لطالما انتقد الايطاليون نقص التضامن
الاوروبي معهم في مواجهه ازمه الهجره انهم
وحدهم من استقبلوا هذا العام ما لا يقل عن
130 الف وافد عبر البحر المتوسط وذاك ضعف
عدد من وصلوا في هذه الفتره من العام
الماضي
معنى من مدينه فلورنسا في ايطاليا فيدريكا
انفانتينو الباحثه في مركز سياسات الهجره
بمعهد الجامعه الاوروبيه في فلورنسا مرحبا
بك سيده فيدريكا نحن نتحدث عن رقم قياسي
للمهاجرين تقريبا 7000 مهاجر غير نظامي
وصلوا الى غضون اسبوع هل يوجد تفسير
للاسباب وراء ذلك
السبب معقد للغايه وبالتاكيد فان الهجره
هي ظاهره معقده للغايه نحن نرى انه
بامكاني ان يكون هنالك اسباب عديده
تفسر وصول هذا العدد الكبير الوضع مثلا في
تونس بالتاكيد ليس وضعا سهلا وقد راينا
ايضا هجمات عنصريه ضد المهاجرين هذه قضيه
اعتقد انها من المهم ان نشير اليها لكن من
وجهه نظر
ما رايناه الان وكيف ان هذه القضيه يتم
التعامل معها
الامر مرتبط بشكل كبير
ببيول كبيره في اوروبا وخاصه من قبل الدول
الاعضاء ولاسباب ربما سياسيه هي تهدف الى
تاسيس عمليه الهجره وخاصه في وجهه نظر
خلال السياقه الانتخابات الاوروبيه التي
ستحصل خلال شهر يونيو 2024 فان عمليات
الوصول لهذه من هي واضحه بشكل كبير لكننا
نبدو اننا ننسى ان معظم المهاجرين غير
الموثقين لا يصلون الى لا يصلون الى
اوروبا فقط عن طريق القارب لكنهم يصلون
بطريقه قانونيه ومن المستحيل
في هذا في هذا الاطار الان ارسل افوندر
العين تقترح هذه الخطه والجوهر يقضي
بتوزيع هؤلاء المهاجرين الذين يستوفون
شروط على الدول الاوروبيه هل باعتقادك هذا
حل ناجع ويرضي الحكومات والسلطات
الاوروبيه
الحلول الجيده مثلا خطه العشر نقاط التي
اتت بها رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه من اجل
التعامل مع هذا الوضع
وهذه الخطه
هي ليست استراتيجيه جديده هي تركز على عده
نقاط من بينها مثلا
الحصول على الدعم من الوكالات من اجل
انهاء عملياتي تهريب المهاجرين
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه ملعني تحدثت
كبيرا عن مثلا عمليات تهريب
والاشجار بالبشر وبطريقه
تنقل فكره ان المهربين هم
السبب مثل هذه الرحلات اذا الاستراتيجيه
تقول اننا نوقف المهربين بالتالي نوقف
عمليات وصول المهاجرين لكن الابحاث اظهرت
ان هذه السياسيات هي تغذي عمليات التهريب
وتجعل من هذا من هذه التجاره مربحه بشكل
اكبر بالتالي يتم استخدام المهربين على
انهم نوع من التفسير لكن لا يتم التعامل
مع الاسباب الحقيقيه للهجره شكرا لك فذلك
انفانتين والباحثه في مركز السياسات
الهجره بمعهد الجامعه الاوروبيه من مدينه
فلورنسا في ايطاليا
الى تطورات في القدس حيث اقتحم ما لا يقل
عن 420 مستوطنا ومتطرفا يهوديا على فترتين
صباحيه ومسائيه باحات المسجد الاقصى
بحمايه امنيه مشدده من شرطه الاحتلال
وقالت الدائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه في القدس
ان المستوطنين قاموا خلال الاقتحامات
باداء صلاه تلموديه وشهدت منطقه باب
السلسله حاله من التوتر مع قيام مستوطنين
بالغناء والرقص واداء طقوس تلموديه لدى
خروجهم من المسجد وكانت قوات كبيره من
شرطه الاحتلال قد انتشرت في بحات المسجد
وعند ابوابه لتامين اقتحامات مستوطنين في
ثاني ايام عيد راس السنه العبريه
كما افادت مراسله الجزيره ان قوات من شرطه
الاحتلال اعتدت بالضرب على عدد من
المرابطين في باب السلسله بالمسجد الاقصى
معكم مشاهدينا الكرام في حصاد هذه الليله
ضمن تغطيتنا
تغطيتنا المستمره لتداعيات الفيضان في
ليبيا والزلزالي في المغرب نبدا بالعمل
انقذوا امراتين على قيد الحياه من تحت
الانقاض في درنه بعد اسبوع على الفيضانات
المدمره في الشرق الليبي فرق الانقاذ
تواجه تحديات انتشار جثث من مباني جرفتها
السيول الى عرض البحر وعمليات تتسارع في
المدينه لاحتواء انتشار محتمل للاوبئه
وفي المغرب جهود لربط مناطق الزلزال بشبكه
الطرقات السلطات تباشر تنفيذ برنامجها
الطارئ لاواء منكوبي زلزال الحوز ووزاره
التعليم تعلن الاستئناف التدريجي للدراسه
بدءا من الاثنين في المناطق الاكثر تضررا
لليوم الثاني على التوالي احتدام المعارك
في محيط مقر قياده الجيش بالخرطوم والجيش
يقصف مواقع للدعم السريع جنوب اندرمان
حرائق في ابراج ومباني عده في العاصمه
وتبادل للقصر المدفعي في مدينه الاوبيض
بولايه شمال كردفان
[موسيقى]
ونبدا من تداعيات السيول في ليبيا بعد
مرور اسبوع على الكارثه
[موسيقى]
اعلن الهلال الاحمر الليبي انقاذ شقيقتين
على قيد الحياه في منطقه حي الصحابه
بمدينه درنه وقال متحدث باسم الهلال
الاحمر ان السيدتين اللتين يتراوح عمرهما
بين 20 وخمسه وعشرين عاما نقلت الى
المستشفى
وتتواصل في هذه الاثناء جهود اجهزه
الاسعاف الليبيه بمسانده فرق اجنبيه للبحث
عن المفقودين وجثث القتلى جراء السيول
وبعد اسبوع على الفيضانات يكثف الهلال
الاحمر جهود لتجميع المواد الطبيه
والغذائيه لتلبيه احتياجات مدينه درنه
وبقيه المناطق التي اجتاحتها السيول
تواصل فرق الانقاذ في مدينه درنه الليبيه
ليوم السابع العمل على ازاله انقاذ
المباني التي دمرتها السيول في محاوله
لانتشال الجثث والبحث عن مفقودين في
التقرير التالي يرصد مراسلنا تامر الصمادي
جانبا من عمليه انتشال الجثث ويروي لنا
قصص اللحظات الاولى للاعصار على لسان منع
يشوه
يهودرن التلملم جراحها
الفاجعه كبيره والخساره اكبر
يحار المرء في ماهيه ما جرى لقد اقتلعت
احياء وطرقات وحياه من جذورها
اتواجد الان في منطقه وادي درنه هذه واحده
من اكثر المناطق التي تعرضت للكارثه
الالاف من البشر لا زالوا تحت الانقاض في
عداد المفقودين في عداد الموتى الرائحه
المنبعثه من تحت تلك الانقاض من خلفه
رائحه صعبه للغايه
المحاولات لا زالت متواصله لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه
علي احد ذوي الضحايا لم يستسلم للياس رغم
مروري وقت ثقيل يمني النفس بايجاد اي من
افراد عائله شقيقه العالقين تحت الانقاض
على قيد الحياه
خيال شيء خيال شيخ خيال يعني مهما تقول
مرض حتى العالم اللي بره ما يصدقكش والله
المستعان نحن نطلب من الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يوحد بلاده ويهدي العباد
بالله
تبحث فرق الانقاذ عن اي بصيص امل يقودها
الى احياء
تحذيرات تتوالى من حدوث الوباء بقاء الاف
الجثث دون انتشال في ظل شح الادوات ينذر
بكارثه صحيه خطيره
لذلك تعمل السلطات على مواجهه ذلك الخطر
او تاخير وقوعه يحاول محمد اخفاء وجعه لقد
فقد زوجته وطفلته كل شيء اي شيء ما عاد
عندنا شيء طيب العائله بتاعنا كل الصقر لا
اله الا الله محمد رسول الله اكثر منك
والله ما عندي حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
وبارك الله في هالناس اللي كلها فزعتنا
طلبت حياه المدينه راسا على عقب يتحدث
خليل بالم عنتبعات ذلك اليوم الكئيب والله
بيوت
وبنته عمي علي عمي علي رحيم هو واولاده
الشرطه العسكريه اثنين
يعني كارثه يعني مهما نوصف مش هنوصف فوق
متسونامي والله
وجهك في درنا ستجد خرابا ودمارا
المدينه غارقه بالجثه غارقه بالهموم غارقه
بالوجع والماساه تتضاعف يوما بعد يوم في
ظل نقص المساعدات والامكانيات
تناشد السلطات ارسال مزيد من المدد تتحدث
عن تضرر الاف المنازل والمباني وتتهيا
لاخلاء اجزاء كبيره من المدينه
ساعات ثقيله كئيبه طويله تعيشها فرقه
الانقاذ على طول السواحل في درنا كل ما
ياملون به هو الوصول الى كامل الجثامين
الى كامل الجثث التي ابتلعها البحر في هذه
الماساه الكبيره والمحققه بالمناسبه هذا
واحد من اكياس الجثه اكياس الجثامين التي
وفرتها السلطات المحليه لنقل المتوفين
تباعا
لقد تحول البحر الى مقبره كبيره وهو لا
يتوقف عن لفظ من جرفتهم السيول انها
الكارثه بعينها حين لا تبقي ولا تذر صمادي
الجزيره
درنه
من درنا ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره محمد
البقالي مرحبا بك محمد يعني ايام صعبه تمر
على المدينه واهالي المدينه ومن دون شك
عليكم ايضا
بالفعل الانس هي ايام صعبه والحقيقه ان كل
يوم تتكشف معه اكثر فظاعه الكارثه
ويتجلى معها حولها لانه منذ اليوم الاول
الذي حدث فيه هذه الكارثه لم يكن احد على
الاقل من الذين كانوا خارج المدينه يتوقع
ان
الكارثه ستكون بهذا الحجم سكان المدينه
والذين تعرضوا لها عالموا بالامر لحظه لكن
كل من كان يوجد خارج المدينه كان يتوقع ان
الامر ربما يتعلق بكارثه طبيعيه سيكون لها
ضحاياها ولكن الى هذا الحد لا احد كان
يتوقع ولذلك نلاحظ الان ان الارقام التي
تعلن الارقام الضحايا قد تصارعت بشكل كبير
من بضع مئات الى بضع الاف بل هناك من يذهب
الى اكثر من 11 الفا وفقا لتصريحات المكتب
الاممي وبطبيعه الحال مساله الارقام هذه
تثير نقاشا هناك تضارب في الارقام ووزير
الصحه
في الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان تحدث
اليوم في مؤتمر صحفي وقال ان عدد الضحايا
الذين تم التاكد من وفاتهم هو يتجاوز
ثلاثه الاف ومئتين
شخصا واكد في الوقت ذاته ان وزاره الصحه
المعينه من قبل البرلمان هي الوحيده
المخوله لاعلان الارقام المتعلقه بهذه
الكارثه وذلك في اشاره الى الرقم الذي
اعلن عنه
او اعلن عنه المكتب الامم المتحده المتعلق
والذي يتحدث عن مقتل
11200 واكثر من ذلك بشكل عام مساله هذا
التضارب لا يخفي بغض النظر هل يتعلق الامر
ببضعه الاف باكثر من عشره الاف ولكن هذا
لا يمنع من ان الكارثه كبيره والمؤكد ان
هذه الارقام هي في ازدياد مستمر خاصه وان
عدد المفقودين كبير نتحدث عن عشره الاف
مفقود تقريبا وهذا الرقم لم يشكك فيه احد
وبالتالي هؤلاء المفقودون لا يتوقعوا انهم
جميعا على قيد الحياه بل ان معظمهم
سيكونون في عداد الموتى بالنظر الى ان
اسبوعا قد مر على هذه الكارثه ولكن رغم
ذلك في ظل هذا الوضع القاتم والماساوي من
بين الفينه والاخرى تاتي بعض الاخبار
الساره كما ذكرتم اليوم تم الاعلان عن
العطور واخراج فتاتين شقيقتين نجتا بعد
اسبوع هذه الانباء تعيد الامل في ان على
الاقل في صفوف العائلات التي ما زالت تبحث
عن ذويها وايضا تقلل جهود عناصر الانقاذ
بانها لم تذهب سودان علاوه على عمليه
الانقاذ هناك الان
هاجس اخر يؤرق الجميع وهو محاوله استخراج
الجثث
الجثث بالالاف ربما وهي
تتناسب مع عدد المفقودين بعضها يوجد في
البحر حيث حمل السيل اعداد هائله من
السيارات من بل رمى ببيوت باكملها عندما
دمرت وصل حملها السيل ووصل بها الى البحر
والافراد ايضا الذين حملهم السيد سواء
اولئك الذين كانوا في سيارتهم او في
بيوتهم كثيره على كل حال لا يمكن الجزم
برقم كنا شهودا هذا اليوم على استخراج عدد
من هذه الجثث على الاقل اخرجت اليوم
بالعشرات هناك
مصدر من الهلال الاحمر تحدث عن نحو اربعين
جثه تم استخراجها من مختلف المناطق اليوم
ومساله الجثث هذه تثير ايضا مزيدا من
المخاوف بشان الاشكالات الصحيه المتعلقه
بها هذا بالاضافه الى مساله التحقق من
هويه هذه الجثث حتى يطمئن ذووها ويقيم
حدادهم وربما يعود الى حياتهم ان تمكنوا
من ذلك اشكرك حتى الساعه جزيل الشكر محمد
البقالي مراسلنا من درنا
ومن درنه معنا الدكتور هلال ساسي مستشار
او عفوا مدير مساعد مساعد مدير مستشفى
درنه دكتور هلال ساسي ما حقيقه اوضاع توفر
الدواء والمستلزمات الطبيه حاليا في
المدينه
ايوه نعم اولا
نترحم على اهلنا في مدينه درنه ونحتسبهم
عند الله شهداء
في هذا المصاب الجلل ونسال الله العلي
العظيم ان يشفي جرحانا انا لله وانا اليه
راجعون نعم اختي الكريمه الوضع
الصحي
جيد جدا في مدينه درنه
[موسيقى]
نعم مستمر الى الى الان قوافل طبيه
من جميع ربوع ليبيا من الشرق والغرب
والجنوب
ووزاره الصحه التي اتت
بمقرها وقامت مستشفى ميداني بساعه مئه
سرير
مع وجود ادارتها بكامل داخل هذا المستشفى
يعني انتم تستطيعون الحصول على الادويه
وجميع المستلزمات الطبيه الذي التي
تحتاجون اليها في هذه الظروف والاوضاع
نعم نعم
تم توفير جميع المستلزمات الطبيه والادويه
بكميات وافره ذكرت ان وزاره الصحه اقامت
مستشفى الميدانيا ماذا عن بقيه الجهات
المانحه والمساعده ما اعداد المستشفيات
الميدانيه حاليا في المدينه
[موسيقى]
هذا الوادي الذي جرفه السيل يقسم المدينه
الى منطقتين منطقه غربيه ومنطقه شرقيه
تم تجهيز ثلاث مستشفيات بالضفه اللي هي
الغربيه من الوادي وثلاثه مستشفيات
الاقسام الاساسيه يعني من المستشفى لقسم
الباطنيه والجراحه والنساء والتوليد
والاطفال
اسس بعض المستشفيات من جميع الاقسام بضفه
الوادي
وبالضفه الاخرى الشرقيه والغربيه بنفس
الاقساميه طيب ماذا عن موضوع اكياس
الجثانين التي كان هناك شكوى من انها غير
متوفره بالاعداد المطلوبه نظرا الى
الاعداد الهائله كما يبدو من الضحايا
نعم هناك عدد هائله هناك
ارقام هائله من الجثمين وما طرح به وزير
الصحه
من الاعداد هي الجهه المخوله
بالاعداد
المفقودين وجثمين
وبالنسبه لاكياس متوفره يعني لا يوجد
عندنا نقص باي شيء من نسبه من من الاكياس
من فرق الانقاض من من من اناس من فرق
متخصصه في جمع جثث
يعني
ما هي ابرز التحديات الان التي تواجهكم في
في ظل هذه الاوضاع
[موسيقى]
اللي هو الناس متخوفه من اشاعات
وهاجس الاوبئه او التي ستنتشر في المدينه
من من الجثمين من هذا من هذه هذا
ولكن لا توجد اي حاله سجلت الى حد هذه
الساعه الى حد هذه اللحظه
تذكر بوجود اي اي امراض معديه ولا ولا ولا
ولا ولا ولا ولا اشكرك دكتور هلال ساسي
مساعد مدير مستشفى درنه ضيفنا من درنا
شكرا لك
من داخلي مقر رئاسه وزراء حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه في ليبيا ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره احمد خليفه احمد ماذا عن عمل
حكومه الوحده في هذه الازمه ومساهمتها في
جهود الجاريه هناك لانتشال الضحايا
ابرز التطورات السي في الساعه الاخيره كان
هو المؤتمر الصحفي للفريق الحكومي الذي
اعلنت فيه عده نقاط تتعلق بالمجهودات
الحكوميه كما تعلمين ال سي في العاصمه
طرابلس تتردد اصداء ما يحدث في درنا هذه
الاصداء تسير في خطين متوازيين خط حكومي
رسمي وخط مدني اهلي الخط المدني الاهلي
يتمثل في تسيير التبرعات
وقوافل التبرعات التي لا تنتهي حتى الان
يتحدث الناشطون الذين يسيرون هذه القوافل
انهم لن ينتهوا منها حتى تنتهي ازمه درنه
اما على المستوى الحكومي فالفريق الحكومي
يقدم اجازه صحفيا كل يوم لوسائل الاعلام
ابرز ما ورد فيه اليوم هو ان افراد جهاز
الاسعاف والطوارئ العاملين في مدينه درنه
انتشلوا خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه
الماضيه
من مواقع ادى في مدينه درنه ايضا الناطق
الرسمي للحكومه محمد حموده اعلن ان
الحكومه لن تتوقف عن ارسال المعدات
والاغاثه الى درنه وانها تطلب تعاونا من
المجتمع الدولي المنظمات الدوليه والمجتمع
ايضا المحلي قبل ذلك ال سي التقينا اليوم
رئيس الحكومه عبد الحميد دبيبه في غرفه
العمليات بشركه الخدمات العامه عندما
تحدثنا معه عن الازمه وتداعياتها قال نحن
الان نفكر في تجهيز مدينه درنه واعاده
الحياه في الى مدينه درنه ونفكر في
المرحله المقبله يقول عبد الحميد دبيبه
هذه المرحله فرقنا الحكوميه والتنفيذيه
والاجهزه الطبيه التي توجد لها مراكز هنا
في العاصمه طرابلس واتجهت منها فرق من
العاصمه طرابلس وايضا من عده مدن ليبيه
اخرى سواء في الجنوب سواء في الشرق
يقول انها تعمل على الارض وتنجز عملها
بشكل جيد وقال انها ان اعمالها تسير بنسق
جيد هكذا وصفها ايضا عبد الحميد البيبه
وصف ما حدث في دارنا السيول والفيضانات
قال انها صدمه اربكت الجميع واربكت العالم
اجمع قبل ان يستجمع قواه ويبدا في انقاذ
الموقف في درنه ايضا تحدث دبيبه للجزيره
قال ان اهالي درنه يعتزمون الان انشاء
مجلس تسيري لاداره المدينه بشكل رسمي وقال
ان حكومته ستدعم هذا الاجراء وستدعم اي
اجراء اخر من شانه ان يخفف على اهالي درنه
وان يدير المدينه بشكل جيد وايضا وعد
بتقديم المساعدات وقال ان حكومته لن تتوقف
عن ذلك
ما عدا ذلك هناك الخدمات اليوميه في مدينه
درنه من انتشار الجثث تسير بشكل جيد حسب
ما تؤكد الحكومه هنا من مقراتها الرئيسيه
في العاصمه طرابلس شكرا جزيلا لك احمد
خليفه مراسلنا من طرابلس
في اعقاب الكثير من الكوارث ولا سيما
الكبيره منها تطلع السلطات والمنظمات
والمجتمعات المحليه والسكان والمتطوعون
بمهام عمليه انتشالي وجمع الجثث وادارتها
الفوريه ويعرقل جهود الانقاذ والبحث عن
المفقودين والجثه في حاله ليبيا تركم
الحطامي وغمر المياه لاماكن كثيره لهذا
تشير بروتوكولات الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيه
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر الى ضروره
الاسراع في تحديد الوكاله المسؤوله في
مجال اداره الجثث مع منحها مطلق الصلاحيات
والمسؤوليات التي تشمل جمع المعلومات
وتوحيدها ووضعها في سجل المركزي مع
التواصل مع الناس في هذا السياق جاء اعلان
النائب العام الليبي وضع خطه بالتعاون مع
وزاره الداخليه والصحه لتحديد جثث
المفقودين والتعرف على هويتهم ووفق دليل
اداره الجثث بعد الكوارث للاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيه الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
ينبغي جمع وتصويرها فوتوغرافيا باسرع وقت
ممكن قبل تحللها وجمع المعلومات الاساسيه
عنها مع تسجيلها وتخصيص رمز دليلي خاص لكل
جثه وينبغي تخزين الجثث مؤقتا لحمايتها
وتيسير التعرف على هويات اصحابها كما يجب
وضع قائمه تضم اسماء المفقودين وجمع
المعلومات عنهم تحديد هويه الجثث تحد اخر
عام 84 وضع الانتربول بدعم من الفريق
العام المعني بتحديد هويه ضحايا الكوارث
اول دليل للتحديد هويه ضحايا الكوارث ويمر
ذلك باربع مراحل اولاها فحص مسرح الحدث
ويمكن ان يستغرق اياما او حتى اسابيع
وبيانات ما بعد الوفاه من خلال مختصين في
الادله الجنائيه بما يساعد على تحديد هويه
الضحيه وبيانات ما قبل الوفاه بتحصيل
السجلات الطبيه او المتعلقه بالاسنان
وبصمات الاصابع والبصمه الوراثيه ثم
مطابقه معلومات ضحايا من لم تحدد هويتهم
بالمعلومات عن المفقودين لعل الحاله
الليبيه في خصوصيتها مع جرف السيول الالاف
ومساحات واسعه ومبانيه وسيارات تكمن في
صعوبه تحديد العدد الحقيقي والنهائي
للضحايا بل والمفقودين ففي ظروف الفوضى
التي تسود في حاله الكوارث كمثال غالبا ما
يتم الابلاغ عن شخص مجهول المصير عده مرات
لجهات مختلفه من جانب افراد اسرته والى ان
تتضح الصوره يبقى عداد الموت والمفقودين
مفتوحا فالعثور على جثث يعني بدايه مسار
للتعرف عليها لكن المفقود يبقى اكبر ضاغط
نفسي على عائله تنتظر خبرا بشانه وقد لا
تعرف عائله اخرى اصلا ان لديها مفقودين في
السيول ففي حالات عده جرفت السيول عائلات
ممتده باكملها فغرقت معها قصتها ولم يبقى
منها من يرويها
من طرابلس ينضم الينا موسى لمجاريف وزير
التعليم في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه سيد موسى
المجارف ماذا عن الخسائر التي لحقت بالجسم
التعليمي من جراء هذه الكارثه بعد هذه
الكارثه هل لديكم اعداد وارقام في هذا
المجال
طبعا
بدايه الحقيقه هي كارثه بمعنى بمعنى
الكلمه يعني كارثه حقيقه يعني كبيره جدا
جدا
وهذه الكارثه يعني لم لم تتوقع يعني من
قبل السواس سكان المدينه او حتى الجهات
المختصه سوى الارصاد الجويه او الجهات
الاخرى المسانده لذلك
فبالتالي النظر للبنيه التحتيه الضعيفه
لمدينه درنه والمدن المكوبه التي تعرضت
الى الاحصار حقيقه كانت يعني
اضرار كبير بالمباني وهذه المباني من
ضمنها هي مباني المؤسسات التعليميه كوزاره
التربيه والتعليم بحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
عملنا في في خطوط متوازيه وايضا كاضو في
لجنه الطوارئ والاستجابه السريعه المشكله
من حكومه الوحده الوطنيه من السيد رئيس
الحكومه
شكرت بالوزاره اللجنتين اللجنه الاولى هي
تختص بالعمل الهندسي والمشاريع الهندسيه
وعمل عمل هندسي بحث واللجنه الثانيه تختص
بالعمل الفني ومشينا حصر المؤسسات
التعليميه بخصوص اعاده انطلاق العام
الدراسي وكما تعلمون صدر قرار من حكومه
الوطنيه
ماذا عن الجسم التعليمي الاساتذه التلاميذ
في ظل هذه الاعداد الكبيره من القتلى
والمفقودين هل توصلتم الى ربما احصائيه
بشان الخسائر في هذا المجال
هي حقيقه الى هذه اللحظه لم يتم وفاهنا من
اللجنه المختصه التي تعمل على الارض في
مدينه درنه بعدد الضحايا بشكل بشكل دقيق
ومفصل باعتبار ان كل
الجثمين التي تم انتشالها او تم العثور
عليها هي الان قيد قيد
لدى اللجان المتخصصه وبالتالي جزء كبير لم
يتم التعرف عليه فتم حصر عن طريق السؤال
البحث الجنائي او او الجهات الامنيه
الاخرى عن طريق الدي ان اي والبصمه
العشريه ومن ثم بعد يكتمل هذا العمل كله
يتم اعطاء احصائيات النهائيه
مفصل الى هذه اللحظه لم ليس لدينا اعداء
وعلى ما تصفها لنا
كانت الظروف على ما تصفها لنا سيد موسى
هذا اضافه الى ازمه اخرى نتحدث عنها يا
ازمه النزوح كذلك عن المدينه كيف تعتزمون
اعاده اطلاق العام الدراسي في ظل كل هذه
الازمات
نعم زي ما ذكرت في بدايه حديثي هناك
لجنتين تم تشكيلها اللجنه الاولى تختص
بحصر الاضرار في المدن المكتوبه وفعلا هذه
اللجنه بدات في حصر الارضاب وحصر المؤسسات
التعليميه وايضا اللجنه الموازيه ويجتمع
هذه اللجان معا دائما بشكل يومي وبشكل
دوري
بتحديد المدارس التي تم شغلها من قبل
الناجين والنازحين من من مدينه درنه اذا
كان رجعنا للاحصائيه المناطق المكوبه ويصل
الى حوالي ما بين
المدارس المتضرره والمدارس التي تم جزء
منها الان ليس ليس الاحصائيه النهائيه
التي تم شغلها بالنازحين تصل الى 98
مؤسسه تعليميه لو لو رجعني الى الى مدينه
درنه هناك عدد من المدارس ولدي احصائيات
الطلبه الذين كانوا موجودين بهذه المدارس
يصل عدد المدارس في مدينه درنه الى حوالي
سته عشر سته عشر مدرسه الذي تعرضت الى الى
الى
اضرار بالنتيجه نتيجه الاحصار وهذه
المدارس يوجد بها اعداد من من الطلبه مثلا
لو اخذنا عينات مدرسه عمر بن الخطاب
324 بسبب ضيق الوقت نشكرك مسالم جريف وزير
التعليم في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه من
طرابلس شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الى المغرب وجهود احتواء تدعيه الزلزال
تتواصل اعمال الاغاثه بعد تسعه ايام من
زلزال الحوز اذ تواصل الهيئه الاغاثيه
جهودها لاواء المنكوبين وعلاج الجرحى
يتزمل ذلك مع بدء تفعيل البرنامج الحكومي
الطارئ لاواء من فقدوا منازلهم
في غضون ذلك قالت وزاره التعليم المغربيه
ان دراسه ستستانف بشكل تدريجيا ابتداء من
يوم غد الاثنين في المناطق الاكثر تضررا
من زلزال الحوز وقد بدات وزاره التعليم
المغربيه بنصب 150 خيمه وستجهزها بالمعدات
التربويه والتدريبيه اللازمه والالواح
الشمسيه لاستخدامها كمدارس وقالت وزاره
التعليم ان الاستئناف التدريجي للعمليه
التعليميه سيكون عبر ثلاثه انماط هي
الدراسه في الخيام والدراسه في الوحدات
المتنقله بالاضافه الى نقل المؤسسات
التعليميه بتلاميذها وكوادرها من المناطق
المتضرره الى مناطق اخرى امنه وبعيده
في اقليم الحوز مركز الزلزال معنا مراسل
الجزيره المختار العلاوي المختار كيف
يتطور المشهد ونحن ندخل الاسبوع الثاني
على وقوع هذا الزلزال
مع انخفاض درجات الحراره الان تبدو
الاجراءات الاحترازيه للاهالي اكثر
تمظهرا خصوصا على مستوى خيماتهم هنا نشاهد
على سبيل المثال هذه الخيمه هذا المواطن
بدا بوضع الحجاره وايضا بوضع اغطيه
بلاستيكيه على هذه الخيمه البسيطه في ظل
انخفاض درجات الحراره قبل قليل كنا في
اسني والان في تحناوت وخلال الساعات
الماضيه كانت هناك زخات مطريه خفيفه في
هذه المناطق لكن هناك نشره انذاريه
للارصاد الجويه تقول ان هناك من المتوقع
ان تكون
زخات مطريه قويه لكن بعيدا عن هنا خاصه في
المناطق مناطق الشمال الشرقي للمملكه في
وجده في جرسيف في صفرو وبقيه في الشمال
الشرقي للمملكه وبالتالي ايضا لاحظنا خلال
الساعات الماضيه انخفاضا تدريجيا والان
هناك انخفاض لدرجه الحراره هذا على مستوى
المناخ على مستوى الاستعدادات ليوم غد غدا
ستبدا الدراسه بشكل تدريجي ولوحظ في هذه
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال بناء خيمات
ستتحول الى مؤسسات دراسيه في ظل وجود او
تضرر اغلب المؤسسات الدراسيه اكثر من 160
مؤسسه
التعلميه مدرسه واعداديات وثانويات تضررت
بفعل الزلزال وقالت الوزاره ايضا انها
ستنقل حوالي سته الاف تلميذ من المناطق
المتضرره في ايغيل وبقيه المناطق التي
ضربها الزلزال وبقوه الى مدينه مراكش
والمناطق الامنه نقل تلاميذ مع الاساتذه
مع مختلف الكوادر التعليميه وبموازاه مع
ذلك ايضا تم نقل مجموعه من الوحدات
المتنقله التي سيتم فيها الدراسه بالاضافه
الى الخيمات في شق المباني الاله للسقوط
وعددها خمسين الف بنايه غدا ستبدا السلطات
المحليه
مع مختصين في المجال بمراقبه وضعيه هذه
البنايات خمسين الف بنايه ليبدا مسلسل
تعويض المتضررين وهي التعويضات التي اعلن
عنها بيان
القصر الملكي شكرا لك المختار العلاوي من
اسني في اقليم الحوز مركز الزلزال
وقال مدير المركز الاستشفائي الاقليمي
بمدينه تارودانت المغربيه ان المركز
يستقبل نحو 130 مصابا يوميا اضاف ان وزاره
الصحه ترسل بعض المصابين لمستشفيات مدن
المجاوره لتسريع عمليه علاجهم مراسل
الجزيره ايمن الزبير رصد لنا جانبا من
اوضاع هؤلاء المصابين وظروفهم في احد
مستشفيات مدينه تارودانت
مع وصول فرق الانقاذ الى بعض القرى في
اقليم تارودانت يتواصل تدفق بعض الجرحى
على المركز
الاستشفائي الاقليمي في مدينه تارودانت
قصص
تروي كيف كانت ليله الفاجعه وايضا كيف نجا
بعض سكان القرى المنكوبه مثل سعيد سعيد
الحمد لله على السلامه ديالكم
كيف نجوتم يعني من هذه الفارسه
الدوار كامل
الشمعه ديال الجمع مشات
للمرضى اللي تحالو على الحسن الثاني
مستشفى الحسن الثاني باكادير وانزكان
اتباعه باش يكون السرعه
العلاج ديالهم شكرا بالاضافه الى هذه
المستشفيات التابعه لوزاره الصحه هناك
ايضا مستشفيات ميدانيه اقامها الجيش
المغربي بدورها تعالج المصابين وتخضع
بعضهم لعمليات جراحيه ايمن الزبير الجزيره
من المركز
الاستشفائي الاقليمي في مدينه تارودانت
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث تجددت المعارك الضاريه في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش في العاصمه
تزامن ذلك مع اندلاع حرائق في مباني
حكوميه ورئيسيه بالخرطوم وستقصف متبادل
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع واتهم
الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني من سماها
المتمرده باحراق مباني شركه النيل الكبرى
للبترول وبورجي وزاره العدل وهيئه
المواصفات والمقاييس
يعود مقر القياده العامه وسط العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم الى واجهه التطورات
الميدانيه في ظل استمرار موجه المعارك
والاشتباكات العنيفه في محيطه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع التي اندلعت مساء
السبت الماضي وانهت هدوءا قارب الاسبوعين
تبادل القصف بين الطرفين ادى كذلك الى
تصاعد اعمده الدخان الكثيفه في سماء
الخرطوم اثرا اندلاع النيران في عده مباني
رئيسيه ابرزها البرج الذي يضم مقرا ومكاتب
شركه النيل للبترول
المواجهات امتدت الى رقعه واسعه شملت مدن
العاصمه الثلاث الخرطوم وخرطوم بحري وام
درمان فضلا عن مدينه الاوبيض غربيه البلاد
اذ اكد مصدرا في الجيش السوداني تدمير
الجيش قوه من الدعم السريع الشرقيه مطار
الخرطوم وكبدها خسائر في الارواح والمعدات
كما هاجم بالطيران والمدفعيه الثقيله
مواقع لخصومه جنوبيه وشرقي الخرطوم اضافه
الى عده مناطق في الخرطوم بحري واضافه الى
هجومها على مقر القياده العامه تقول قوات
الدعم السريع انها قصفت اهدافا في منطقه
سلاح المهندسين وسطاء ام درمان كما اتهمت
في بيان لها الجيش بتعمده قصف البنى
التحتيه والمناطق الحيويه في الخرطوم مثل
وزاره العدل وديوان الضرائب وبرج شركه
النيل للبترول وتزامنت هذه المعارك
المتبادله مع عوده رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان الى البلاد بعد انهائه
زياره رسميه لاوغندا استمرت يوما واحدا في
خطوه تعد السادسه من نوعها منذ مغادرته
مقر قياده قواته وسط الخرطوم قبل ثلاثه
اسابيع واتخاذه مدينه بورتسودان مقرا
مؤقتا وسط معلومات تحدثت عن اعتزام
البرهان تشكيل حكومه طوارئ لاداره البلاد
الى حين التوصل الى تسويه تنهي الحرب
المستمره منذ منتصف ابريل الماضي في حين
هدد قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو بتشكيل حكومه موازيه بالخرطوم وقال
في تسجيل صوتي الخميس الماضي ان قواته
ستبدا مشاورات لتشكيل ما سماها سلطه مدنيه
بالمناطق الخاضعه لسيطرتها
في الاستوديو معنا ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني مرحبا بك سيد
ضياء الدين بلال لماذا باعتقادك استعر
القتال بهذا الشكل الضاري اليوم في
الخرطومين هنالك اشتعال لهذا الصراع وواضح
ان الدعم السريع يقع تحت الضغط قوي بانه
لا يستطع طوال هذه الحرب التي تقارب الان
اكتمال السته اشهر ان يسيطر على مقر رئيسي
من مقرات الجيش واذا تحدثنا عن المغارات
الرئيسيه نتحدث عن القياده العامه للجيش
نتحدث عن المدرعات تتحد ويندوز عن قاعده
وادي سيدنا نتحدث عن
المراكز القوات الخاصه كل هذه السلاح
الاشاره كذلك فكل هذه الاماكن لم يستطع
الدعم سريعا يسيطر عليها كذلك لم يستطع
الدعم سريعا يسيطر على مدينه واحده حتى في
الاماكن التي توصل بانها قريبه من محاضنه
الاجتماعيه في دارفور لم يستطع ان يسيطر
على مدينه كبيره فبالتالي هو يدعي خلا
ويقول انه يسيطر على اجزاء واسعه من
العاصمه الخرطوم وحتى يهدد بانه سيذهب نحو
تشكيل اداره مدنيه لهذه الحكم له وجود وله
انتشار ولكن ليست له سيطره كيف يمكن ان
يقول بانه يسيطر وهو الى الان لم يسيطر
على على قاعده عسكريه واحده من القواعد
الكبرى في الخرطوم الحديث عن اقدامه على
تشكيل اداره مدنيه لهذه المناطق اعتقد انه
يستطيع ان يفعل ذلك لانه لا يملك ارض يمكن
ان يؤسس من خلالها وليس له حلفاء في العلن
على الاقل من المدنيين يمكن ان يشكل منهم
هذه القوه بالعكس هو يجد الرفض واسع من
القطاعات المجتمعيه السودانيه ولا يجد
مصرا الا في في بعض المناطق وبعض الزعماء
العشائريين ولكن القاعده الاجتماعيه له
تكاد تكون القاعده الضيقه جدا حتى الذين
يوصفوا بانهم قاعده ضيقه ماذا لو قام
باعلان بالاعلان عن التشكيل مثل هكذا
مجالس او مجلس مدني كيف سيكون الرد سيكون
اعلام معلق في الهواء دون ان يكون له مقدر
على التنزل على ارض الواقع فبالتالي
يمكنه ان يعلم ذلك ولكن لن تكن هنالك
تجليات له على ارض الواقع ولن يكون هنالك
له حيز على ارض الواقع ستكون فرقه اعلاميه
لا اكثر ولا اقل طيب راينا هذه الجولات
الخارجيه للبرهان اخرها في اوغندا لماذا
اوغندا وما الذي اسفرت عنه هذه الزياره
اوغندا دوله مؤثره خاصه في الايقاظ وفي
الاتحاد الافريقي
وهنالك تعاطي وتفاعل من قبل الايجاد
والاتحاد الافريقي مع الملف السوداني وهي
تبدو اكثر احتدالا من الموقف الذي تتبناه
كينيا او الموقف الذي عبرت عنه اثيوبيا
فبالتالي اعتقد انه
البرهان يضع لهذا الامر وان يوغندا لم
تشارك في في تلك المواقف التي كانت تبدو
مندده بالحكومه السودانيه او بالسلطه
القائمه في السودان فبالتالي هو يسعى الى
مد الجسور اذا كان انت هذه الجسور ممتده
نحو الدول الافريقيه المؤثره على الواقع
السياسي السوداني او نحو الدول العربيه
اذا كان ذلك بزياره قطر ومصر والدول
الاسلاميه بزياره تركيا كذلك شكرا لك ضياء
الدين بلال الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني ضيفنا هنا في استوديو الحصاد
في هذه الاثناء نقلت وكاله رويترز عن
مسؤول في البيت الابيض انه واشنطن لمست
بوادر محدوده لدى بيجين بشان امكانيه
اجراء محادثات بين جيشي البلدين
قال الرئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه الجنرال مارك ميلي ان الصين
سترتكب ما وصفه بخطا استراتيجي فادح اذا
شنت هجوما عسكريا على جزيره تايوان اضاف
ميلي في حديث لشبكه سي ان ان الاخباريه
الامريكيه ان بلاده لا تسعى لصراع مع
بيجين لكنها تستطيع صد هجومها على الجزيره
في حال حدوثه
هل يمكن ان تسد الولايات المتحده الغزو
الصينيه لتايوان ان حصل
ممكن بكل تاكيد الولايات المتحده ما تزال
متمسكه بقانون العلاقات مع التايوان
والضمانات المصاحبه له نحن نريد التوصل
الى نتيجه سلميه بين تايوان والصين لكن من
الناحيه العسكريه اعتقد ان الصين سترتكب
خطا استراتيجيا كبيرا اذا حاولت الهجوم
والاستيلاء على جزيره تايوان لكن ربما لا
تكون القدره العسكريه الصينيه قادره على
فعل ذلك فقد تحدث الرئيس سيجيم بينج علنا
عن الحاجه لتطوير قدرات جيشه بحلول العام
2027 ما يعني انهم يعرفون انهم لا يملكون
القدرات لمهاجمه تايوان الان
من بيجين ينضموا الينا فيكتور جاو نائب
رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه ومن واشنطن معنا
ماثيو المستشار السابق بوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه مرحبا بكما سيد فيكتور جاو ماذا
كانت تريد الصين من وراء هذا اللقاء
شكرا على الاستضافه اعتقد ان الاجتماع بين
الكبار الدبلوماسيين في مالطا كان مهما
جدا اعتقد انه كان هنالك تقارير تم
نشر الخبر في الصين وكان هنالك خبر ان
وزير الخارجيه الصيني عبر لنظيره
الامريكيه عن القضايا المهمه وخاصه في
قيمتها تايوان وايضا عده قضايا بين الصين
والولايات المتحده اعتقد ان نقاط الاساسيه
بسيطه جدا وقد كانت متسقه من الجانب
الصيني ومعناها ان الصين ليس شكل تهديدا
للولايات المتحده ولا يجب ان تشكل
الولايات المتحده ايضا تهديدا على الصين
وانها هذان الاقتصاد اقتصادا كبيران في
الولايات في العالم يجب ان يتعاون مع
بعضهما البعض بدلا من تهديد بعضهم البعض
بالتالي كانت فرصه جيده للتاكي على
المبادئ الاساسيه
والمصالح المشتركه بين البلدين
ماذا عن الولايات المتحده
ما الرساله التي ارادت ان تبلغها للصين
في خلال هذا اللقاء
انا اوافق ان لا اجتماع كان اجتماعا مهما
وان اداره بايدن قد اعترفت ان العلاقات مع
الصين قد اصبحت تنافسيه بشكل اكبر خلال
السنوات الماضيه وقالوا ان من المهم جدا
مع ذلك ان يكون هنالك قنوات اتصال منفتحه
مع كبار السياسيين والدبلوماسيين لتبادل
الاراء واعتقد انه يحقق هدفا اولا مناقشه
القضايا الصعبه التي قد يختلف فيها
البلدان مثل تايوان وايضا هو الاساس
لتعاون المستقبلي وبعض الاخبار التي
انبثقت من هذا الاجتماع مفادها ان الرئيس
بايدن والرئيس الصيني قد يلتقيان لاحقا في
خريف هذا العام بالتالي هذا تطور ايجابي
لاظهار انه سيكون هنالك تواصل مستمر على
اعلى المستويات بين البلدين لكن هل مثل
هكذا لقاءات سيد مافيو تخفف من الهواجس
والمخاوف الامريكيه لاسيما بشان تايوان
لا اعتقد
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده لديها ما تزال
لديها بواعظ قلق انه وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه قالت ان الرئيس الصيني طلب من
الجيش ان يتهيا لغزو تايوان في عام 2017
وقد زادت الصين من خرقها خرق طائراتها
للمجال الجوي في تايوان بالتالي الولايات
المتحده ما تزال قلقه لكن مثل هذه
الاجتماع قد تكون مفيده لان الولايات
المتحده والصين بامكانهم ان يتبادل ارائهم
فيما يخص الوضع وحتى ولم يجدوا حلا على
الاقل فان مثل هذا الحوار قد يمنع السوء
الفهم ويساعد على فهم موقفي بعضهما البعض
بشكل افضل هل توفق فيكتور جاو يعني مثل
هكذا لقاءات هل هي بالفعل تمنع سوء الفهم
وتغير هل تلمس الصين انا مثل هكذا لقاءات
تغير التعاطي الامريكي معها
بالنسبه لتايوان اسمحي لي ان اركز على
التالي ليست الصين هي التي تغير الوضع
الحالي في مضيق في المضيق لكن الولايات
المتحده هي التي تستمر بتحدي سياسه الصين
الواحده ما قامت به الصين وانا متاكد ان
الوزير الخارجيه الصيني قد اخبر نظيره ذلك
في مالطا ان الولايات المتحده يجب عليها
ان تتحدى هذا هذه السياسه وعليها ان تحترم
هذه السياسه سياسه الصين الواحده والتي
كانت موجوده منذ عام 1971 الزم ميلي
الامريكي تحدث عن الامكانيات العسكريه
دعيني اقتبس رئيس سابق لتايوان ماي جو
الذي اعلنا انه منذ
الستينيات ف الصين تمتلك امكانيات عسكريه
لتحرير تايوان هذه هي الكلمات التي
استخدمها في الستينيات بالتالي السؤال
التي يجب ان تطرحه لماذا الصين لم تستخدم
القوه العسكريه منذ بدايه الستينيات
للسيطره عن طريق القوه السؤال الذي طرحته
هو نحن نعرف ان هذا الخلاف هناك خلاف
واختلاف في وجهات النظر حياه ما يجري في
تايوان ولكن السؤال هو هل مثل هكذا لقاءات
تؤدي الى تخفيف التوتر بالفعل كما قال
السيد باثيونين وهل تخفف على الاقل من حده
سوء الفهم انجازت وصفه بذلك
فلسفيا هنالك نقطه عن كلما زادت عدد
الاجتماعات وخاصه فيما يتعلق برؤساء
الولايات المتحده والصين انا اعمل انه
سيؤدي الى استقرار اكبر في العلاقات
الثنائيه من جانب اخر اعتقد ان السيد وي
وزير الخارجيه قد اوضح للجانب الامريكي
انه زياده الاستفزازات من الولايات
المتحده ضد المصالح الاساسيه للصين سيتم
لقاؤها بنفس الشيء بالتالي ليس هنالك اي
تردد وغير عدم وضوح فيما يتعلق بالدفاع
الصين عن مصالحها وسيادتها وسلامه اراضيها
لا يجب ان يكون هنالك اي سوء فهم في
واشنطن ان الصين لن تتحمل اي تهديد
لمصالحها الاساسيه اعتقد ان هذا يجب ان
يكون الاساس الذي
سيجتمع فيه رئيس بايدن والرئيس بينغ
في وقت لاحق هذا العام ما في هناك معطى
مهم في خضام كل ذلك وهو ان اداره بايدن
الرئيس بايدن نفسه في خضام معركه انتخابيه
حاليا لاعاده انتخابه هذا الامر كيف من
شانه ان يؤثر على التعاطي مع السياسه تجاه
الصين
اعتقد انه سيكون عاملا قد يلعب دورا اذ ان
التحديات الصينيه واهميه الصين هي قضيه
توافق بين الحزبين اذ ان الحزبين اتفقنا
على يتفقان على ان يكون اولويه لكن هنالك
انتقاد لاداره بايدن
لتلهفه للقاء الرئيس الصيني اعتقد ان هذا
الاجتماع مختلف لكن خلال السنوات عفوا
خلال الاشهر السته الماضيه كان هنالك
مسؤولاني من اداره بايدن للسفر الى بيتين
الاجتماعات لم يكن هنالك اي مسؤول صيني
ياتي الى واشنطن مثلا لاجتماع مع
المسؤولين الامريكي بالتالي هنالك بعض
الجمهورين الذين يقولون ان الولايات
المتحده تقوم ببذل الكثير من الجهد
وهذا الامر يجعل من الولايات المتحده تبدو
بموقع موضع ضعيف بالتالي لا اعتقد ان هذا
الامر ربما قد يستمر بوجود نوع من
الانتقاد لاداره بايدن على انها كونها
ضعيفه ومتلهفه بشكل كبير للتعاون مع الصين
شكرا لك المستشار السابق بوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه من واشنطن وفيكتور جاو نائب
رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه من بيجين
بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختامي حصاد هذه
الليله نشكر لكم متابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]